thank you
[Music]
so uh we're gonna get right into it
because there was this woman who was
stolen as a child that has just been
reunited with her family isn't that just
called kidnapped
yeah
redo the title there was a woman who was
kidnapped I understand
and has been reunited with her family
after 53 years whoa dude that's a long
time 53. that's ridiculous right so
Susan Gervais I think that's how you
pronounce it people forget by then
though yeah does it really matter like
imagine like your most favorite dog
right and then you lost them
like [__] like when you're seven at
60 they're like we found them
you're like I don't really give a [__]
bar you didn't you didn't give birth to
your dog I know but I'm just saying I'm
just trying to relate to something and
plus a dog that
there's all like
I don't know it's not close enough
how about taika okay good
kidnapped not stolen he's one or two
she was kidnapped when she was four no
that's four four
suddenly suddenly Bart's like damn this
is crazy
this changes everything why did you say
so okay so the half-life of feelings is
four and then after four more years
you're like I only care about him half
the mount and then another four years
with a half the amount by the time it's
12 years in you're like who's like uh
that's all I kind of remember here and
there another 16 20 I don't know 50 days
a long time yeah yeah so you think on a
scale from one to ten ten being like Oh
I'm gonna miss this kid so much yeah I
can't wait and then to one like where
would you rank that I don't know because
I'm thinking about
if you do the math right yeah 53 years
if I lost Tycoon is 54 Tyga's 57. you
know how ugly's gonna be yeah so I see
tiger at 57 yeah how old am I a [__]
like
90 hundred
with the 57 year old man it's like I'm
not gonna be like oh remember when we
used to do this I'm [__] shaking the
[__] out of him what if you're young too
what if you were like only like 50 and
he's also 50. a what whoa
he got arrested by time cop that's what
happened
my son's older than me yeah dude that's
that's what happened that's all we have
Jason here to ask the questions that
people need answers to he got stuck in a
Quantum Leap and didn't leap yeah so
Susan Gervais disappeared in 1969 after
a family offered to take her to Disney
World in Florida but never brought her
back just four years old at the time
Susan says she was snatched and taken
around the world to Canada New Zealand
and Australia by her new mom and dad oh
my God speaking about her life Susan now
grandmother said as a child I lived with
my six siblings in an old vicarage on a
traveler's site we aren't we weren't
Travelers my mom was her own was on her
own and we were all in and out of foster
care I was befriended by a couple on the
site who were from Scotland the woman
who I call my mom now had Ms and had two
sons I think they wanted a girl
they asked my mom if they could take me
to Disney World and she gave them my
birth certificate so I could be put on
their passport whoa what the [__] that
was an inside job yeah instead they took
me to Canada then Australia and later
New Zealand this was always their plan
the couple told Susan and others that
she had been put up for adoption and
that they had taken her in but while she
never realized what was going on at the
time Susan says she had a great life I
lived with the traveling community and
lived a cherished life where I was
spoiled rotten wow that's [__] crazy
that's crazy that was the best case
scenario yeah seriously she said my mom
died from Ms when I was 10 but even then
being raised in the hub of a traveling
Community I was very loved I have always
been happy growing up I traveled the
world back home however her biological
family feared they would never see her
again with her mother searching
desperately for her and within the mom
sell her off no so the biological mom
who didn't who was taking care of six
children and didn't have a husband or
anything like that to help out in that
little Community one of the other
parents or Mom and Dad they had two
brothers and one and a daughter they
told her that they were going to take
this biological mom's daughter to Disney
World and then never brought her back oh
and they basically conjured into also
receiving the birth certificate for like
passport information or whatever but
really just kidnapped the daughter but
they kidnapped the daughter not because
it was one of our regular JK stories
where it's like let's kidnap somebody
and sell them into like sex slavery or
some [__] this was yeah no I'm really
proud of it
if you guys could um stop [__] with
my dignity and integrity on the show
that'd be great I just thought I was
proud of you so uh she she had two sons
but apparently always wanted her
daughter and she had a Ms which is what
is multiple sclerosis yeah right so she
was already in her life knowing that
everything was degenerating and and so I
guess in a final in what is assumed kind
of like a plea of life she did kidnap
this girl in order to fulfill one last
thing but did it with some sort of
integrity and wanted to actually treat
her like a good daughter and stuff and
showing the world she kind of like
arguably rescued her then in a way yeah
just illegally yeah very illegally yeah
so the back home like we said the
biological family was definitely still
tragically fearing that they would never
see their actual daughter and searching
for her so they actually reported it and
had like and but apparently police never
got involved it's thought because Susan
had been in and out of foster care and
her mother had allowed her to go on
holiday with the couple so it's already
kind of like a problem family that was
probably already on the radar of like
you know social services or whatever
like that but it was only when Susan
came to upgrade her passport that she
became suspicious as she couldn't see
any record of her adoption
so that's when her husband then put on
an appeal on an Australian Facebook page
and she was reunited with four of her
six siblings back in West Yorkshire the
couple flew over to the UK recently to
finally meet up with them after all
these years and had a party to celebrate
Susan's now 57th birthday and Susan said
the enormity of what happened to me
didn't hit me I just carried on with my
life it was only when somebody who who
was adopted asked me what my family back
in the UK would be feeling and that was
a light bulb moment for me when I spoke
to my family they were crying
hysterically because I was alive but
sadly Susan's biological mom died eight
years ago and never knew where she had
gone or that she had been found hey
that's still a pretty long life for her
having MS and stuff that's pretty good
no no the uh the biological mom didn't
have MS oh the the mom that kidnapped
her had Ms and wanted to like have a
daughter before like her life was over
so they stole this daughter and then six
years later that mom died did all his
original siblings survive to meet her
again so uh I think she meant four of
the six and it says luckily however her
sister who is ill currently uh got to
see her before her condition
deteriorates
so like they're all old as [__] and
they're all definitely like right at the
edge kicking the can she just traveled
with the dad in The Traveling community
so with with the mom as well for the for
six years yeah and then after her mom
died of Ms she kept on going with that
Community but to her knowledge she was
already put up for adoption she doesn't
know anything about her biological
appearance of getting swindled in a
sense you know what I mean in her mind
at four she was put up for adoption and
now her new mom and dad or her real
loving parents that like legitimately
are taking care of her and that's all
she knows so she never had that
perception yeah without awareness if you
want a kid that you want to kidnap you
gotta do it when they're real young
thank you yeah yeah you don't wanna for
supporting me you don't want to get at
Bart's level right where they're like uh
cognizant enough to like fall in love
with their parents as well dude right
you gotta get them because there's some
way crazier stories there's this
documentary on Netflix called abducted
in plain sight you ever heard that one
no that one's [__] up tell us about it
Cliff Notes this guy kidnapped this
daughter in like Utah like four or five
different times with some girl yeah the
same girl and the parents kept like
because he kept like infiltrating their
family what if he had sex with a mom
he what yeah he he messed around with
the dad too like he coursed them into
doing all that these are good Cliffs and
he kept [__] kidnapping the daughter
this guy's room now infiltrating this
show's on Hulu they have a live action
show on Hulu for this that's crazy
this is a great story compared to that
one this family's [__] defense sucks
ass
for the month to have sex all the time
the dad could get to do whatever you
want and he keeps stealing the daughter
away bro he that's not Phillip Jackson
he stole the he kidnapped the daughter
and her when she was like 13. geez we
have a rifle for that word oh sorry
sorry
and then ends up hooking up with Mom
later down the line and then convinces
the dad to jerk him off in the car
what and this is true because the dad is
he's telling the story
the dad's the one he's like yo he we
were looking at records we pull over
we're at it we're looking over a cliff
somewhere and the kidnapper the Molester
I didn't mean to point at you but
yeah just been having a hard time with
you know insert wife's name Barbara or
something you know having a hard time we
haven't really been intimate he's like I
just need some release and the dad is
explaining this story from his point of
view and he goes okay so he [__] Jays
him off in the front seat it's so sad
like the amount of chaos that you could
create the combination of a nefarious
individual and a low IQ family yeah you
can wreak total Havoc yeah it's [__]
up it's real [__] up [__] I feel like
one of those events would trip me out
really bad like my world would be in
shambles if if I let some stranger yeah
jerk me off I'll be like I'll be like
you know he's a friend oh then that's
right overlooking a cliff so there's a
moment yeah there's a moment you took
him to a view he took him to make out
point and I was like yo let me go play
we had a great day and then right when
you bust when the sun just peeks right
over the hills and it's like a sunrise
oh my God that is beautiful
no idea
[Music]